round four of the US and US Women's  Championship here in st. Louis the winds  keep coming fast and furious as the top  players in the nation maintain their  fighting ways in a bid for the country's  national title disaster struck world  championship candidate Fabiano Caruana  when he pushed tomorrow and lost against  a Linda CIA's OREA allowing Sam Jenkins  win against Ray Robson to vault him into  a three-way tie for first in the ladies  section it was a perfect six wins out of  six games with Ozzy McKenzie landing a  LUMO against Anna Tsarevich and 15-year  old anyway needing over a hundred moves  to take down Jenny for you to maintain  her surprising position atop the  leaderboard action shows those signs of  abating as the cutthroat games continued  round five action coming